dans les yvelines de nombreuses
animations auront lieu pour les 37e
journées du patrimoine parmi elles une
visite originale de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est la compagnie à une paix hull
agence nationale de psychanalyse urbaine
qui s'en chargera l'idée est de
découvrir sous un autre angle les lieux
où l'on passe tous les jours on se rend
pas vraiment quand en fait de tout ce
que l'on dit en regardant sur
l'environnement toujours sous le mans
sous le mans sous le même angle pardon
est là
l'idée c'est vraiment de décaler drogue
le regard et de se dire en fait comment
se fait-il que je n'ai pas vu cette
chose qui sous mes yeux
le point de rendez vous est donné au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
14h30 le samedi 19 et le dimanche 20
les organisateurs rappellent que la
réservation est obligatoire et que les
participants marcheront deux à trois
kilomètres
autre événement coup de coeur ce
week-end des spectacles de danse
verticale
ça veut dire que c'est une danse qui est
ouverte est possible pour tous les âges
absolument et pas seulement pour les des
grands habitués de la danse
contemporaine mais vraiment pour tous
les publics
l'idée dé cette pratique c'est
d'utiliser les murs des édifices ou des
bâtiments pour danser la ville pour nous
est un espace qui est complètement
ouvert à notre à notre danse et en plus
on quelque part on invente un nouvel
usage à la ville puisque
on vient on arrive avec nos cordes no
baudriller tout ce matériel d'escaladé
mais avec un avec une recherche
chorégraphique des spectacles de danse à
découvrir à montigny le bretonneux et à
elancourt